So this company is ripping off our
Number one video of all time. Why is Google letting this happen? How do we stop this guy? Like
Clint!, hang on man hang on, i cannot hang any longer dude
Hey guys, are you about to click away because you think that this is an advertisement today's sponsors today's sponsor today's sponsor today's sponsor
This is a sponsor segment shame on you. It's not
But I did want to bring up something that you might not even know is happening
We've all seen pre-rolls on Facebook and Instagram and YouTube and what-have-you. Where an
advertisement pops up before you watch video
It's one of the ways that we generate revenue to
Continue to make more videos and if you guys have been watching this channel for a while
You probably know that I'm a licensed attorney and I've talked a lot about content and copyright infringement in the past
But today's video explores something much more nefarious
Okay, we got sent numerous emails about this and they were saying hey guys this company that has these lucid dreaming
Masks is using Superman with a GoPro as an advertisement for a product. Are you guys related to this product at all?
And not only have they taken our Superman with a GoPro video. They've taken content from numerous other creators
They've cut together in a minute-and-a-half ad and then they've posted that on their Facebook profile and then they tell Facebook
Hey
We'll pay you money
Put this video as a pre-roll all over your site
Now with everything going on around Covid and the unemployment rate and all the other problems that are associated with that whole mess
this might not seem like the biggest deal but as a content creator and
on behalf of the other content creators who make the videos that you watch those videos are our product and when somebody takes our product
and uses it in a manner that we don't intend that hurts us and it hurts you guys as the viewers too
The hardest part is that this isn't the first time that this has happened not even in the least
I mean just a few months ago. Nico was dealing with something just like this at the studio
Sam
can I show you something
See this now yes the past so there's exam
it's making like
Minecraft mod ripoff programs on Android and they're using our minecraft video as their commercial
They should do that because that's stupid and their mod probably sucks. It's actually not a mod
it's just they took other people's mods and made a program that lets see like
Install mods on Minecraft Pocket Edition without having to pay for them
It's one thing to like using obscure videos video of ours
But like to use our like number one video and just rip us off or their own
commercial and now at the face of their crappy company and their crappy app
They're rippin us off to ripping off the modders. They ripping off the customers knowing YouTube
There's probably not much we can do about it. So I think they like like hey, you're something cool. I want to share it
It's something to like here's something cool. I want to monetize it because I want to make money from other people's work
That's not cool. I'd like to send him an invoice and make him pay for using it
Let's see if what Jake says we can do about this. We need my lawyer
So, how do you stop something like this from happening
Well first and foremost when you guys the viewers tell us about it when you see it happening. That is the
Most immediate way that we find out about it
But it's also the most manual it's the slowest
Because what we have to do is we have to then go to the product search around the internet
Try to locate where the video is coming from and then ask the people who take it down
Do you think we'd send an invoice?
Like here's the price for using our content sending them an invoice for a thousand dollars isn't gonna do anything at all
Like you're talking about somebody that probably lives
Somewhere in some major city in Vietnam in order to keep for you to advertise on YouTube
You have to upload the video to YouTube if they downloaded the video from YouTube and then re uploaded it to YouTube
Why didn't Content ID recognize that why is Google letting this happen?
There is no way to tell the platform
That somebody is doing this and so even if we go after mr. Kingdy
Himself, and he takes it down the door is still open for other people to do this
so ultimately the responsibility I think lies with Google if you're a company like Facebook or Google and YouTube you've got
billions of pages
literally and you've got billions of ad dollars coming through your site every year you have a you have a responsibility to look after the
Advertisements and the way that they're run on your platform and ensure that things are running smooth and that things are playing by the rules
because right now it doesn't matter where you got the content from you can just go on there and
Put it in from a millions of people depending on how much money you're willing to spend
Now you might be thinking Jake how is this different than what you guys did with the Superman properties
Do you don't own the rights to Superman?
You don't own the rights to Minecraft and you used those characters in those worlds and a bunch of different videos
Well, the answer lies in what is called fair use
Now well, this is not an affirmative right within American copyright. It is a
well-recognized defense of
additional creativity that goes into one's work
Now obviously in Superman with the GoPro we started with the Superman character of what we do not own
But then we took it and we created an entirely new video from an entirely new perspective
That people hadn't really seen before and the focus wasn't really on
Superman it was on the perspective of
What it's like being Superman it might not sound like much it might sound like so what's the difference?
You still took it and used it and did whatever you want with it
But there's actually a huge distinction to be made between that and then simply
taking someone else's video
Re uploading it within your own advertisement and selling your own product based on that video. I think you get what I mean
We can do about it outside of like I hoping that you know
Big old Google like somehow changes corporate policy for us. Is there anything you can do about someone driving like a maniac on the freeway?
honk at them I
Mean, I guess we could do the equivalent of honk at them and maybe give them the finger you could maybe ask the audience to
Go give bad reviews on the app. I
Don't like mob justice, I hate mob justice. It's such a thing on the internet now
Everybody just takes a couple of facts they run with it and they like destroy someone's career and I don't want to like inspire mob
justice, where it's like guy, let's go just like destroy this person, but
How do we stop this guy like alright here's here's what I think we should do
We're gonna send them an email and say cease using our video immediately and tell us once you've done
So if we do not hear back from them, it's on the horn. I ask people to start reporting them for violation
Don't look up their address don't send them Molotov cocktails in the mail. I don't think you can do that
So those emails off to date be posted? I need a way to de-stress very thing AMD stress within this office
This is a crash pad crash pad is what you can jump onto from high distances and not hurt yourself Oh
For that you need a big
You know watching back through this footage which we shot long before any of this coronavirus stuff even started
It made me realize how lucky we are to make the videos that we make and that's due in no small part to our loyal
Patrons over at patreon.com/corridordigital patrons like glitch cube
not a Canadians by Alan Almanza Philip Oxford harris bret zapata
jordan mattes bot Kurt Sunil s
Daniel Webster and Philip women. Thank you for supporting new content
Is safe wren does that brain damage he's just always like that oh you have to do though, right?
We jump off the job, yeah
You scared wrong
Bikini on any longer
Check this out
She went up there
It's been a few hours since I sent off the original emails asking these people to remove these videos and
fortunately
the people from
lucid dream masks Co got back to me and they said we reviewed all of our content and we will take down all the
posts and videos that contain the footage
We want you to know that our intention
Wasn't to deliberately steal clips from your videos and we can assure you that this won't happen again. Thank you very much
I totally understand. You know, when a company is new you're trying to get started. You see a cool piece of video out there. I
Really appreciate that
Realistically the solution to these types of problems clearly lies with platforms like Facebook
Regardless of who creates the content or where it comes from or who owns it?
If you guys like this video and you want to know more about what goes on here at corridor
We have a podcast where all we do is tell stories talk about projects. We're working on things. We think are funny things
We think are interesting. It's a great time
if you're into podcasts head on over to youtube.com slash cord or cast or or click the link in the description right here or
Over there the link here. Anyway, we just said seam icon check it out
Don't feel like
You actually get yourself you didn't take it back back up not for I gotta go though, I gotta go I'll catch you guys
You forgot this bag